♪ ♪
>> Sean: NEW REPORT FROM
FOX NEWS DETAILS EXTENDING THE
NEW YORK’S UNUSED HOSPITAL BEDS
AND VENTILATORS WHILE LAYING OUT
WHY THAT RANGING MISMANAGEMENT
AS WE TOLD YOU, NEW YORK STATE
DIRECTIVE WAS STILL CONTAGIOUS
CORONAVIRUS PATIENTS INTO
NURSING HOMES.
THANKFULLY, FINALLY, NEW YORK IS
ABANDONING THE STUPIDITY AND
SOME OF THE DUMB AWFUL PARTS OF
THAT POLICY ON TOP OF PUTTING
CORONA, COVID-19 PATIENTS AND TO
NURSING HOMES WHEN THEY HAD A
HOSPITAL SHIP CONVERTED FOR
COVID PATIENTS, 3,000 HOSPITALS
MANNED BY SOMEBODY ELSE WAITING
TO HELP THEM THAT THEY BARELY
USED.
182 PATIENCE, THAT’S ALL THAT
EVER WENT ON BOARD IN THE NAVY
HOSPITAL SHIP COMFORT.
NEW YORK HEALTH MISSION OR
HOWARD ZUCKER CONTINUES TO COME
UNDER FIRE AND DUBBING HIM
DR. DEATH.
FORMER NEW YORK MAYOR, RUDY
GIULIANI, THEY DIDN’T BUY THE
VENTILATORS IN THE CITY, AND
INVITE IN THE STATE IN THE OWN
HEALTH COMMISSIONS SAYING THEY
WOULD NEED AN PEAK WEEK AND THEY
DIDN’T BUY THEM.
THEY LITERALLY WERE TELLING US,
MARCH 2ND, de BLASIO SAYING,
GO ON ON THE TOWN.
IT’S SAFE.
IF THE ARROGANT NEW YORKERS AND
IT’S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN IN
NEW YORK AND WERE PREPARED.
THEY WEREN’T PREPARED AND
DONALD TRUMP SAVED THEIR
BACKSIDES.
ALL THAT SAID THAT, THEY PUT THE
ORDER TO SEND THE SICKEST PEOPLE
IN THE NURSING HOMES SCREAMING
WE CAN’T CARE FOR THESE PEOPLE
WHEN THEY HAD THE BEDS
DONALD TRUMP DEALT AND
DEMAND FOR THEM.
IF MR. MAYOR, I DON’T KNOW WHAT
TO SAY ABOUT THIS, 85% OF THE
ELDERLY POPULATION REPRESENTS
THE DEATHS HERE.
>> WELL, SEAN, THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE OF THE LEFT NOT KNOWING
THE RIGHT HAND IS DOING AND THE
MAYOR AND GOVERNOR AS FAR
AS I TOLD MATT ABOUT TWO DAYS
AGO.
THAT’S JUST HORRIBLE.
THE ONLY WAY YOU CAN MANAGE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS AS A
UNITS AND THE MOMENT 9/11
HAPPENED AND FROM THE MOMENT I
ESCAPED FROM THE PLACE WE WERE
TRAPPED, I CALLED THE GOVERNOR
AND HUGH AND I WERE PARTNERS FOR
THE NEXT THREE MONTHS.
WE HAD OUR STAFF MEETINGS
TOGETHER, WE MADE OUR DECISIONS
TOGETHER AND THE WHOLE IDEA
ABOUT BODIES -- A COUPLE DOZEN
BODIES WERE DISCOVERED OUTSIDE A
FUNERAL HOME RUNNING FOR TWO OR
THREE WEEKS.
ONE OF THE FIRST THING WE
ANTICIPATED WHERE THE NUMBER OF
BODY BAGS AND FUNERAL DIRECTORS
WE NEEDED AND FOUND OUT WE WOULD
NEED TO MANY BECAUSE
UNFORTUNATELY, THE BODIES IT
DISINTEGRATED.
WE IMMEDIATELY BEGAN THE DNA
SITUATION.
WE HAVE PREPARED FOR THIS.
WE HAD EIGHT OR TEN DRILLS OVER
THE LAST SIX OR SEVEN YEARS TO
PREPARE FOR TRAGEDIES AND FOR
CRISIS AND FOR ANTHRAX AND SARIN
GAS.
I WONDER HOW MANY SUCH